let's go next to Alex from California
Alex welcome
hey David can you hear me yes I can
hey David so um have you covered the 60
second 60 Minute interview from Joe
Biden and about Taiwan I covered the
interview in terms of Biden saying that
the pandemic is over I did not cover the
Taiwan piece I was so busy early in the
week that I didn't even watch the entire
interview I just did a story on the the
covet part
okay so
um I'm curious because every time Joe
Biden says something about Taiwan like
if China invades we're going to send
troops but every time that happens it
always seems that the White House always
backs pedals and say oh we don't know
about that or oh uh we don't stand by
that um what do you think about that I
think it's typical posturing it's you
you you you say something the President
says something a little hawkish and then
we're when there's a request for a
clarification you sort of walk back a
little bit and say it's not our intent
or it's not what was meant I think that
that it that is completely standard
political posturing to sort of keep
those that you consider your adversaries
a little bit unbalanced where it's not
totally clear exactly what they're
willing to do it's like a minor version
of when Putin talks about launching
nukes
um I I think it's just typical posturing
it's politics
all right so
um if let's say somehow or for some
reason China does invade Taiwan yes do
you do you believe that America should
step in with their like not just like
what sending funding to Taiwan but like
sending troops like American troops to
like how about Taiwan I am not ready at
this point in time to say that the U.S
should get involved militarily in
defense of Taiwan against China I
believe that China would be wrong to
invade Taiwan of course but I am very
careful about the declaring support for
American Military interventions so right
now I can't tell you that I would
support that I would have to study the
issue more
that's fair but like I feel like if you
know Canada does invade Taiwan uh I feel
like that would set like a bad president
if America doesn't do something because
like you can't Ukraine is doing well
because we're sending a bunch of AIDS um
to their way but uh in the case of like
China and Taiwan I feel like this is
like a really different situation yeah
the scale is completely different and
the circumstances are completely
different listen I agree I think that
military action would ideally happen in
Coalition and
um I am not at this point ready to say
uh that I would say yes the U.S needs to
get in there
um one final thing
um do you believe that
um people or people are comparing like
the China Taiwan situation to Russian
Ukraine and saying how
um how Russian is doing poorly and how
things are not going in Russia's favor
during the war and people believe that
that might reflect or might be this
situation if China invades Taiwan
because I think that that it is a
totally different situation I do not
think it is logical to extrapolate from
how Ukraine is doing uh how Taiwan would
do I I don't think that that would be a
fair
um assess a fair assumption
okay
um that's all David day for thank you
for taking my call all right thank you
Alex from California very very important
declaration